where is Peter Salinger's going to talk
about a finite alternation result for
this Peruvian circles okay thank you
very much so circuits so boolean
circuits as you know are built from
gates and or not 116 5 10 has
experienced an internal error okay and
boolean circuit of course how has whoops
we learn how to use the pointer here it
has some inputs often we take the
circuits to just have a single output
but of course they can also have
multiple outputs and so a circuit really
describes a function from 2 to the N 2 2
to the M where to is the set of
bullion's and sometimes the function is
reversible meaning invertible okay and
sometimes it's not but the point is that
bullying circuit you know even you know
it's a mat you could imagine that n is
equal to M and that you have that the
function that you're describing here is
actually a bijection between the inputs
and outputs but even when this happens
for bullying circuit then the the sort
of components of the circuits are not
invertible just maybe the circuit as a
whole and in reversible computation
including quantum computation you want
all the components to be reversible so
for this reason people look at
reversible boolean circuits so these are
usually built from also from gates okay
but but this time we use reversible
gates as the building blocks and the
three most common ones introduced by
Toffoli are the knob gate the scene
arcade and the toefl e gate and this is
what they this is what we usually write
for these gates and what they do is well
the not gate just negates the bullion
and the control not gate or also known
as the sea not gate would negate X if
and only if Y is equal to one and then
the toefl e gatewood negate X if and
only if y and z are both equal to one
okay so it's relatively straightforward
to see that every that a reversible
boolean function on n bits can be
decomposed into these three gates
okay this can always be done when n is
less than or equal 3 and then when n is
greater equal four you can only do it
for even permutations so it would a
boolean a reversible boolean function is
a bijection on a finite set in other
words a permutation and permutations can
be even or odd like you know doesn't
matter if it's on the set two to the N
orientation is even if it can be written
as a product of an even number of
transpositions right and the and of
course it's easy to see that if you take
for example this thai fully gate here
and you add a fourth wire where it's
just the identity a fourth input w okay
then of course this gate would always
perform an even-par mutation on the 16
possible states because it will always
map 0 X Y Z to something and then it
would map one XYZ to something and it
because it describes the same
permutation on all on the eight inputs
that have W equals zero as on the eight
inputs that have W equal to one it's
always got to be an even permutation so
clearly being even as sort of a
necessary condition if you're going to
have any finite set of generators if you
have a finite set of generators for
reversible boolean circuits and the
largest generator is on n bits then n
plus 1 bits you always get only the even
permutations or in other words though
the whole group is not finite the whole
group out is not finitely presentable
alright so for various reasons i'm
interested in generators and relations
so of course reversible boolean
functions form a group or more precisely
a family of groups because you have one
for every n so the reversible functions
on n bits and in they don't just form
any family of groups but what's known as
a group ID in fact a monoidal groupoid
what this means is that if you have a
reversible function on n bits and a
reversible function on M bits then you
get a reversible function on n plus M
bits in the obvious way by performing
the two factions separately on each of
the two sets of bits right so you get a
monoidal category where all the more
physics are invertible
that's nice when you talk about
generators and relations usually when
you are talking about just a single
group you might talk about some
generators for the group and then once
you have the generators you might talk
about equations that the words in the
generator satisfy and if you're lucky
there would be some finite set of such
equations that would sort of imply all
the other ones but of course if you have
an infinite family of groups you would
sort of need generators for each of the
groups so a typical example that you
probably know is permutation groups
where you have say permutation on on n
objects and then it has n minus 1
generators which are just swapping
adjacent object and then the relations
are well known the yang Baxter relations
you know you have Sigma Sigma I Sigma I
plus 1 sigma i is equal to some other
thing and so on but the point is that
you need sort of if you have n objects
then you need all of n generators and
you need oh of and at least o of n
relations but when you talk about it as
a group point when you talk about when
you also take the monoid structure into
account then you just have a fight then
you just have a single generator which
is to swap two elements and you can just
answer that with identities on both
sides to get all the other generators so
that's why the group hard structure is
often sort of useful okay now for the in
the case of reversible boolean functions
I gave you sort of the toefl e generator
so in general see where you only get the
even permutations but that's fine we can
live with that but there's actually no
complete set of relations known for
these generators so if you get if i give
you two of these toefl e circuit okay
not only is it difficult to decide if
they're equal or not because that has
got to be at least an np-complete
problem you can just reduce the same
problem for a lot for ordinary building
circuits to the reversible one so but
you also we don't even know right now a
complete set of relations for these okay
and why is this a non-trivial problem it
turns out there are many class
circuits for which this problem of
finding generators and deviations has
very easy answers there some groups of
subgroup I'd surface of this group I we
just discussed the simplest example is
the one I already mentioned permutation
circuits where you take as generators
just the swap gates so that would take a
pair of bits and actually permute them
and you can implement up oops you can
implement that in terms of these see not
gates like this and other examples where
the question of generators and relations
is easy our linear circuits these are
the ones where you that are just
generated by C naught so no topoli or
negation kids at the app fine circuits
you get when you also add the negations
and then in quantum computing they're
all kinds of sets of gates I'm just
mentioning here Clifford circuits that's
a some quantum group where the problem
is also easy and what all the easy case
the easy classes of circuits have in
common is that they can be described
recursively okay they all have an easy
and unique normal form normal forms are
great if you're looking for generators
and relations because then you know you
need to write down just enough relations
so that everything can be converted to
normal form so so an example is
permutations here's some arbitrary
permutation circuit but you can use
local laws you know here i'm applying
some laws locally locally locally and
you can prove that in fact every
permutation circuit can be uniquely
written in this normal form which is a
certain staircase pattern at the
beginning and then recursively a permit
a shin on n minus 1 bits ok and and and
you can moreover it's really easy to
show that there's some finite set of
relations by which you can convert
everything to this normal form ok
another example where the normal forms
are unique and easy is linear circuits
so remember I said that the linear
circuits are the ones where you just
have C not as a generator ok so these
correspond exactly to functions on n
bits that are linear as functions over
the vector space you know when you
regard the boolean as GF to write the
two element field so in other words and
of course linear functions on n bits can
always be described by N by n invertible
matrix where the entries are zeros or
want and moreover every such matrix can
be quite easily and uniquely transformed
into the identity matrix by applying
Gaussian elimination so you look at the
leftmost column if the upper thing is
not a one and you permute some columns
and if it is a one then you use that to
eliminate you look at the bottom most
one in the first column and you kind of
bubble it to the top replacing each one
along the way x is 0 and that gives you
again the sort of staircase pattern
which is what you need to fix the first
column in gaussian elimination and then
recursively you do it to the rest of the
matrix so you get these you get this
recursive structure of the chopper
circuits so we can prove stuff about
n-bit circuits by recursively proving
stuff about n minus 1 with circuits and
that is exactly when we have such a
structure then we often have a canonical
form which is recursively defined we can
reason by induction and then we get
rewrite systems for for converting the
circuits to normal form therefore making
the Equality easily decidable it's then
easy to find generators and relations
and sometimes the normal forms are
actually minimal that's not always the
case but if it is then that's also nice
because it gives you a minimization
procedure for circuits of course which
we cannot hope for in in general only in
these easy cases so the exactly what
makes reversible boolean Toffoli
circuits difficult to reason about is
that there is no such known canonical
form and no such an own way of reasoning
about the circuits recursively on the
number of bits usually when you are
given a reversible boolean function and
you wish to convert it to a reversible
circuit then you write down the truth
table of that function and you do
something you know basically fixing one
input at a time to the correct output
okay so that's not by recursion on the
number of bits but by your current on
the number of inputs of course you get
an exponentially large circuit but
that's unavoidable because if you count
how many there are you know some of them
I've got to be exponentially large
so question even if we can't have unique
normal forms can we at least reason by
induction on the number of bits somehow
is there a way to do that and the result
that I would like to tell you about
today is really just sort of this little
result here okay it's not going to solve
the next 99 you know important problems
in theoretical computer science but i
think it is kind of a cute result that
and i don't think it was previously not
so for n greater equal for every even
reversible function on n bits can be
written as a composition of at most 9
reversible functions on n minus 1 bits
which are as in in this diagram here so
first you operate on the bottom and
minus 1 bits then on the top n minus 1
bits and you repeat this nine times ok
of course it's not remarkable that every
even function on n bits can in general
be decomposed into parts acting only on
n minus 1 bits that we already know for
example the toefl e generators right you
can already be decomposed into those but
rather what's remarkable is that the
number 9 here is completely independent
of n okay even if you got you know a
thousand and 24 bits here it can still
be done with only nine alterations okay
and I don't think that nine is the
minimal number that makes this theorem
true I think I proved that it that the
so a lower bound is five ok you can't do
it with four in general but I don't know
someone more clever than I will probably
soon find a way to do it with seven or
or even with five but nine is sort of
what we have make it not dating the top
or bottom depends on in you can you can
fix that you want to start with bottom
for example and then it's still true so
so you get you get one decomposition
that starts with bottom and another one
that starts with top and they both have
length night um so in particular if you
want to compose two of those you can
always arrange it so the middle one
cancels out so then you have 17
alternations instead of 18 so what could
you do with the result like that I was
sort of looking there's not really a
killer application
okay but I'm imagining if I'm looking
for generators and relations for example
I could take an arbitrary boolean
function and first write it in this form
and and you know I could if I find
enough relations that would allow me to
convert any circuit to one of
alternation lab nine then I could
recursively use their relations in on n
minus 1 bits to bring those further to
sort of normal form that's just a wild
idea it doesn't really work because
these normal forms are not unique so you
also need additional relations to
convert any of the non unique ones into
any of the other non unique ones but at
least it's a first step in that really
in that direction it also gives you an
upper bound for the size it's another
way to actually synthesize a reversible
function into a circuit because first
you write it in this form and then you
recursively use the same algorithm on n
minus 1 bits to do it so you get 0 of 9
to the N as an upper bound for the size
of the reversible bullying circuits
that's much worse than the existing
upper bound of course but it's nice
because it has this recursive structure
Yuri make sure you on me offer deep and
low sweet and up early the most
is it is it how you in general there
only to me means that them immediately
that's right he was used a top n minus
one at the bottom and minus one yeah
it's much more special than it's not
just any n minus one bit but you know
those particular ones yes okay now in
fact you could say you could state a
slightly more general theorem of much
more general but the thing to note here
is the the two to the N minus two states
of the middle n minus 2 bits instead of
using 2 to the N bullion's you could use
any set a right even if the cardinality
of that set is not a power of 2 so so
consider let a be any set with at least
three elements then every even
permutation of this set can be written
as a product in this form that's that's
the more general theorem which implies
the other one but once you think about
permutations of a set of the form to
cross a cross to that gives you a kind
of geometric way to think about the
problem ok so imagine that the set a we
think of the settee as the points in
this rectangle here right and then that
to cross a means two copies of it took
if X is any set to cross X mean you
could visualize it as two copies of X
stacked on top of each other and you
could visualize X cross to as two copies
of eggs stacked next to each other and
then to cross X cross to would give you
sort of four copies of the set a here
and a permutation of the form f cross
two would be a vertical permutation
applied so the point is that you apply
the same permutation to these left two
copies of a and to the right two copies
of a and for to cross G it's just the
other way around so every permutation
can can be written as a product of at
least of at most nine of these forms
maybe even one and because it's so nice
and visual I made this into a game ok so
if you're bored right now and you don't
really want to know the proof you can go
to my website here and you can play this
game there is a version for linux and
mac and windows ok and the end i will
play it you know
later I'll show you after we do the
proof okay and it just allows you to
move in exactly those ways and the goal
is to fix the to get the right
permutation in the end okay so outline
of the proof it's basically very
combinatorial comment oral proofs can be
boring so I'll just go through it
quickly and then I'll then we'll play
the game okay the way that we can do
this in 9 alternations is first we use 5
alternations to fix one thing and then
we use for all donations to fix the rest
okay so what we're going to do in the
beginning is we're going to put all that
let's say tiles okay because we're
thinking about this game in the first
five alternations are going to be used
to put all the tiles all the top tiles
in the top and all the bottom tiles in
the bottom okay so let's just think of
all the top tiles as white and all the
bottom tiles as blue we're going to say
that a permutation is standard if it's
if it's already fixed so white is at the
top and blues at the bottom and we're
going to say that a permutation is
symmetric if the if the blue and white
pattern on the left is equal to the blue
and white pattern on the right now it's
pretty obvious that every symmetric
permutation can be turned into a
standard permutation with a single
vertical move okay ya gotta have the
same number of Blues on the left and on
the right so that's definitely a as many
as you need so in fact a permutation can
be turned can be standardized in one
vertical move if and only if it's
symmetric right then we're going to say
that a permutation is regular ah so look
at the vertical columns here there's
only four patterns that a vertical
column can be blue blue white blue blue
white or white white right of these four
possibilities we say that the
permutation is regular if each of the
four possibilities occurs an even number
of times for example here have two blue
Blues and I have two wide whites and I
have four white blues so each of them
and 0 blue whites so each of the four
possibilities occurs an even number
x and of course when that is the case
then you can always transform this to a
symmetric permutation with a single
horizontal move because those pairs
always move together in the horizontal
rule and then and we sort of go you know
similarly okay the next ones are along
similar lines slightly more complicated
maybe two if you wrap your head around
we're going to say it's nearly standard
if its standard except possibly for four
columns okay so here these left this one
this one and that one isn't standard if
there's at most four counter examples
and we say it's nearly standard and you
can prove that every near the standard
thing can be transformed to a regular
thing with the vertical permutation and
then we say it's nearly symmetric if
it's symmetric except maybe in four
places and finally we say it's fair if
it has got the an equal number of white
and blue tiles because surely that is a
necessary condition for being able to
reach whoops for being able to reach the
final state from the initial one and
then you can the proof just shows
combinatorially that in fact you can
start from any fair permutation and do
this this this this this until it's
sorted okay so in fact I have not used 5
i've only used for alternations so far
because that's horizontal vertical
vertical horizontal vertical the true
vertical ones can just be combined into
a single vertical step so we still have
five alternations left so now we know
that all the top tiles are on the top
all the bottom tiles are on the bottom
now we need to orient those tiles okay
so we can use a single horizontal
permutation to just fix the tiles on the
top put them all into their correct
position and now we still have to
perform an operation of the form tau
plus the identity right apply some G
here at the bottom and the identity at
the top and then we use again
combinatorics a presentation is balanced
every permutation has a cycle
decomposition and it's unique okay
uniquely right every permutation as a
disjoint union of cycles and then we say
it's balanced if for every K there's an
even number of case I
okay and this is an example of a
balanced permutation and this is an
example where it's not balanced and let
the dilemma is that if tau is a balanced
permutation then it can be written of
the form a horizontal move followed by
vertical move followed by a horizontal
loop that's relatively easy to imagine
if you had a balanced permutation down
here then you have two copies of each
cycle so you just move one of those
copies to the left and one of those
copies to the right okay in matching
places you can do that use a horizontal
move to do that and then we give you
want to use a vertical move that just
doesn't touch the top half at all but
just fixes this this little square here
okay applying those cycles the same
cycles on the left and on the right and
then you can conjugate them back to
their original positions so and and then
the dilemma that makes the rest of it
work is every evil permutation on a set
of five or more things can be written as
a product of two balanced permutations
ok so again this is sort of cognate
Horrocks you just do it by case
distinction and and with that we have
actually finished the proof right so
this is the end of the of the main
theorem and now all that we have to do
is actually you know I have to prove it
to you now right so let me let me
shuffle it randomly ok so I'm not
cheating here so that's this trick work
so we have to move all the blue and
yellow background the tiles to the top
and all the orange and green back
rounded ones to the bottom so first we
have to make it be nearly nearly balance
and so on so look at all the pairs of a
tile and a matching tile so here we have
blue blue ok and yellow yellow so that's
up up up up going to pair those up then
we have here's a yellow he's a napper
tile in a lower tile we need to find a
matching one somewhere here's an upper
tile
lower tile so these two match these two
match here we have an upper and a lower
here we have an upper and a lower here
we have a lower in the lower and here we
have a lower in the lower so I'm lucky
actually because it really was
randomized this time it's already what
whatever we call this it's already
balanced ok so if I move out so let me
do horizontal moves now if I move this
one over here and I move it's more fun
if you do it yourself actually but maybe
you'll watch me do this so now now it's
symmetric because I have the upper upper
upper upper and the upper upper upper
upper so I can change my direction of
moves here and bring all the yellow and
blue stuff to the top and all the green
and orange stuff to the bottom ok now I
can reverse directions again by the way
this little app is actually counting not
just the number of moves but also the
number of flips ok because that's what
we can minimize ok now you fix the Apple
aunty orange and oh this is really lucky
because the for some strange reason the
strawberry was already fixed you can
calculate the probability of that
happening that's absolutely randomized
there hey I did not make it do that and
now we have to fix the bottom thing so
we have to write whatever permutation
that is done here as a product of two
balanced permutations if we look at it
it's we have to move this guy here here
and here so this is just a single three
cycle actually that I have to do now how
can I write a single three cycle as a
product of two balanced permutations I'm
going to swap these two guys and for
example these two guys that's balanced
and then we're going to swap these two
guys and again these two guys that's
also balanced right so swapping these
two guys and those two guys is easy ok
that was the first of the balance
permutations and now I have to swap
these two tiles and simultaneously these
two tiles so I need to conjugate the
left hand side this messes up the top
but only temporarily now I have to swap
these two and these two which I can do
with a horizontal with a vertical move
and then finally I can unconjugated
congratulations we've actually done it
with six flips ok so this in this case I
was lucky and I only need it alternation
depth seven okay rather than nine so yep
that's basically the the end up and
there's more puzzles here so you can you
know if you if you know how to do the
easy one try that one right and I made
it easy for beginners so in the
beginning because you know it's not so
easy actually if you don't know the
proof in the beginning you just have
fewer colors and then you know so my
kids are you like playing this too
because you know it's easy in the
beginning and only gradually gets
difficult so thank you yep questions
somehow is the flavor of like the
algorithm for solving a Rubik's Cube
it's a little bit similar to the
algorithm for Rick's group yes so not
quite because in a Rubik's Cube you
basically you're looking in a Rubik's
Cube you've been nominated finitely many
what they call algorithms finitely many
of these moves that for example allow
you to swap two of the cubes or three of
the cubes or something here you have in
the final step you do have to look at
the whole permutation and sort of look
at the cycle decomposition so that's a
little bit more than just applying a
finite number of patterns but of course
you could solve this also with the final
you know like this just a move that you
can do to perform saith recycle and then
you could decompose every permutation
into three cycles it wouldn't give you a
bounded alternation depth if you did it
that way but would you would allow you
to solve the puzzle I mean the point of
the research part of the talk was really
define at alternation depth but for
people trying the puzzle they don't they
might not care so deeply they just want
to get it done all right any other
questions yes any any pattern where you
use just n minus 1 the lower bound of
for alternate I think the counter
example uses a three element set for
eight already that you can't do it for
and of course if you can't do it for
some end then you can't do it for any
bigger and either I think not entirely
trivially true but
I think that's true
well into whatever the problem should
get harder when n gets bigger but it
could get slightly easier in the
beginning because you got more
dimensions for a temporary scratch space
or something is that an easier argument
to prove that you need only finitely
many flips not that I know of I mean the
argument I gave is not super difficult
but I don't think there's like a
one-liner that would prove even finite
alternation depth sewed up I talked to
reversible computation people and they
some of them didn't seem to think that I
was plausible even certainly it wasn't
it's not certainly it's not obvious
it would be nice to have already short
proof for some n right and then then use
all the technicalities just to get an
equal to 9 by the way I lied a little
bit well I didn't lie I just omitted a
detail which I out of pure honesty will
tell you about which is that the the
permutation that you are decomposing had
to be even for obvious reasons that's
obviously a necessary condition but
these little white rectangles that I
construct here are not themselves even
they might be odd okay so if you want to
use that method recursively you need to
have even alternation depth of nine
meaning that the fs and the g's are
themselves even for that I'm only able
to prove that as well but I can only do
n equals in 13 I can do it with 13
alternations but not benign okay but I
think that's not at all type our
conjecture that you can also do it with
nine for the even case but I just wanted
to mention it you know full disclosure
okay no other questions yes or no
darling so I have patented it and I'm
working on making a JavaScript version
so it can run in your browser I think
that's the way to go if you want it to
actually become I don't want to see
viral but like if you wanted people to
actually try this it's got to be in a
browser and it has to have a button to
share your result on facebook is it the
way so there's a provisional patent on
it right now because you know I thought
it'd be fun to try and see if like at
least I can make enough money to get the
costs of the patent back
it's probably guessed yet so that be but
on that website did I mention I'm
basically my homepage so I you can't see
that from over there /p game I haven't
come up with a real good name for the
game yet either surely it can't be
called permutation game it's gonna be
like you know for the public so but
anyway right thank you